nell'episodio precedente raga ci sono
rimasta oddio aveva della madre sono
futuro ok oh cazzo è partito un coltello
e buongiorno io io ho preparato della
carne prima voi qualcosa da mangiare e
si ti taglio la faccia è veramente
assurdo io la voglio finire qui per
questo episodio della a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenute questo nuovo video io sono
vari j
oggi siamo tornati su mezzo fa del ragga
quinto episodio stiamo andando avanti
simo ok sono partiti con un filmato
immediatamente partiamo da dio in
pratica vai così
ok non posso muovere le mie gambe
perfetto perché non puoi morire tre
gambe devo salvare mio padre questo l'ha
capito padre ok
beh oddio mi è svenuta
ma questa mi prende le sedi prima di
registrare perché c'è professor layton
sei al tuo limite forse dovresti
fermarti un momento cosa fa adesso mi
prendevi butta a dormire ok ok che che
suo dio ci siamo per ci siamo farà ok
buongiorno buongiorno anche a te questa
è la sveglia ovviamente ci si sveglia
con uno che ti fa
di fianco profumi come la mamma che vuol
dire come fai a profumare con la mamma
gli ha [ __ ] profumo quello il profumo
della mamma come hai preso
brutto bastardo di là melo ok non ha
detto proprio così ma oggi a scappare si
è [ __ ] il profumo ragazzi i ladri di
profumi perfetto ci sia si vede che i
fantasmi puzzano perché qua c'è un cane
spiegatevi perché c'è un cane
ah ok in basso amato è ora che siamo
partiti con un filmato subito cioè non
siamo nemmeno partiti bene allora lega
ci siamo siamo partiti adesso siamo
partiti come un filmato a caso siamo sa
benissimo abbiamo fatto km praticamente
la dov'eravamo prima c'era la stanza di
fianco praticamente va bene direi che
possiamo entrare in questa anche se
sembra vuotano è chiusa perfetta
questo punto direi di andare avanti raga
dell'ultimo oddio ci sono i topi ragazzi
oddio mi scoprono i topi che cazzo
ragazza non ha senso
bene allora ragazzi siamo veramente
l'ultimo episodio che aveva fatto
indietro avevo lasciato delle zone
inesplorate diciamo quindi dopo ci
tornerò
devo capire perché questo rito allora io
ho una motosega o una moto senso tutti i
topi ho trovato la merda ti scoprono
aiuto brani topi via
ok ce l'ho fatto per sorpreso una chiave
ho preso una chiave e sono riuscita a
salvarmi dai topi che mi stupravano
forse aprì la porta si ce l'abbiamo
fatto ragazzi piano piano ho cazzo cioè
ladro del profumo vieni qui al topo sia
al top dice di venire qui non avere
paura
ok cazzo è sparito tutto perfetto
penso che non fosse così buono gli
animali sembrano odiarlo e penso intendo
profumo si madonna che schiaffo ok da
ridarmi il profumo di mamma
ok che cazzo si ride ogni volta questa
ma cos'è cos'è cosa non ce l'hai
dovrei messo ok non lo so io dove l'ha
messo ma non voglio dirlo non lo so ho
guardati intorno e si guardiamoci
intorno è scappato e il fuggitivo dei
profumi cosa cosa non andava in lei non
lo so cosa non andava mai era un
fantasma che rideva in modo stupido
allora ragazzi c'è una crepa nel muro lì
dietro l'ho vista io presumo che debba
tipo triturare noi infatti un cazzo devo
allora innanzitutto devo scassare queste
per forza non a caso un po pro bastardo
okay allora qui dentro non c'è o c'è una
foto c'è la foto di un cane c'è la foto
del cane a sinistra tra l'altro è che il
cane imbalsamato li perfetto che ha un
osso in bocca ma lui non ce l'ha
c'è il cane a 1 st in bocca ma nella
foto ma qui non c'e la perfetto allora
c'è qualcosa qui dietro spostate o cazzo
ho trovato una crepa allora c'è una
crepa nel muro vista dobbiamo tipo vai
cos'è apriamo i pertugi al muro mi
sembra giusto ecco alle motoseghe
e vabbè andiamo avanti ok cos'è
quest'anno a cazzola profumo la mamma
pensavo dovessi trovare l'osso da
mettere nella bocca del cane per poi
prendere il profumo invece no ok grazie
a dio
cos'è oddio mio cazzo mi spuntano gli
zombie merda via scatola star di ok
chiudi la porta già abbiamo fatta se
c'era uno zombie attento che sfonda
perfetto ragazzi all in one proprio
sembra ci sia un messaggio di sangue sul
messaggio hai detto che saremmo stati
una famiglia hai mentito
cos'è
e va bene ma ci sono sempre i topi via
via via via allora io vorrei capire
perchè non posso strutturarli si topi
non posso farlo allora andiamo sotto
punto direi torna voglio solo capire una
cosa da gama sto cane a un osso perché
lì ci aveva un osso però non posso da lì
mica il profumo da mangiare solo un
pochettino cayman
ok sto profumando il ragazzo nuovo devo
fare la pubblicità nuovo profumo per
cani
by favi j cè ci vuole ho dato è angelo
sei messa tua cosa capi braga ci metto
delle ore a capire le cose ma ho capito
la vedete profumo mi pare che i topi
lodino perché prima lo odiavano c'è il
topo era scappato quindi presumo che ora
si allontanino andatevene bastardi
andate bene e tipo repellente per poche
1 praticamente non ti trovano buongiorno
buongiorno sorella qualcosa per me un
cazzo va bene non intendevo proprio
questo se si doveva vomitare poteva
farlo per i cazzi suoi senta io
l'esorcista non l'ho mai visto come film
ma lei ha un ruolo da protagonista che
ci sta da dio è forse non era il termine
adatto comunque andiamo avanti
c'è una porta chiusa qui allora siamo nè
legge ma scusi mi scusi un secondo
[Musica]
bene ragazza puntata non ha senso di
vomito alla gente
i topi scappano ladri di profumi cani
che puzzano c'è di tutto questo caso c'è
anche zombie che f1 a caso e striscia
cinque minuti di episodi è successo di
tutto
va beh direi di andare avanti ha
spuntato non so che cosa ci può
succedere allora la cia il corvo già lo
vedo va bene questo non si apre un
perfetto allora andiamo dal corpo
perfetto ci siamo cosa è quello c'è una
crepa nel muro che già la vedo
e c'è qualcosa dietro a letto raga c'è
qualcosa dietro quel letto lo vedo ma
non posso andarci rivede che devo
sposare letto in qualche modo ma non so
come sa per ragazzi è chiusa la porta si
è chiusa la porta da sola e si aperta ma
l'altra era già aperta credo si era già
allora chi caccia aperta vi prendete per
il culo
chi è o una motosega o una motosega non
ho paura di usarla anche se non ci
taglione anche una scatola
ok non era nessuno io direi di chiudere
non si chiude perfetto anni avanti
questa non sia un pomello della porta è
rotto sembra che non si possa aprire da
questa parte che si apre solo dall'altra
praticamente va bene e forse su anche
come armetti che cazzo succede
qualcuno sta arrivando oddio oddio cos'è
aiuto
cos'è ma che cazzo ma cos'è ma cosa che
cazzo è successo per haga questa è la
prima volta che perdo da quando ho
iniziato medi father questa è la prima
perché arrivano i fantasmi ti stuprano a
caso cioè non c'è verso andiamo avanti a
caso è perfetto se chiuso la porta bene
mi fa piacere dove dovrei andare allora
io vado avanti
poi mi spunta qualche ok scappa scappa
scappa scappa laverda addio ma questa è
fatta
tu sei morti cazzo corre come non so
cosa è possibile
vabbè continua allora ragazzi non
andiamo da quella parte
andiamo allora la porta chiediamo
innanzitutto to sleep perfetto la
vendiamo via
usciamo di quadri salvo di nuovo e mi
avete anche consigliato di salvare in
altri slot perché io sono sempre lo
stesso l'aversa abbiamo in altri slot
non so perché ma noi salviamo va bene
allora andiamo avanti cioè quest'altra
portabagagli non ci vado
no era quello che per speravano
succedesse chiosa merda come faccio raga
un problema questo allo ragazzi c'è uno
zombie di merda che mi scopro cosa devo
fare allora la porta si apre perfetto
cosa dovrei fare qui devo andare avanti
e c'è tipo allora forse ho capito prova
entrare lì dentro ma non so come posso
salvarmi iori che se ce l'ho fatta
the road con stronzo muori muori borst
hard ok ci si prova a sfondare prosa rai
anche io sei volte ma non ce l'hai la
forza di undertaker brutto stronzo
io salvo intanto mi è volato il gufo
guide cieli corvo qui dentro non so
neanche come mai non lo voglio sapere
devo spostare letto posto a letto si poi
spostiamo a letto vaiano veramente rari
posa riposati nel letto vabbè era che
una traduzione o dio
raga qualcuno ha spostato letto e non
sono stato io e non va bene ho salvato
25 volte in un minuto è un record questo
non c entro lì sotto cosa fai
eh no l'ultima volta che sono entrato in
un passaggio così ovvero qualche minuto
fa è spuntato uno zombie e non va bene
non va bene questo siamo ascoltati di
qua perfetto magari cosa devo fare le
soffrire di qua così non se l'aspetta ok
cazzo
entra arriva dall cazzo via mi aveva via
via benevento
che palle forse ho capito live il vaso
il vaso tutto strano vedi il vaso non lo
superi perché sei un tappo del cazzo
cazzo
ho fatto una stronzata sul perché non mi
sta stuprando che succede mi scusi
questa è la parte in cui lei dovrebbe
mettermi le mani addosso perché non lo
fa raga mi si è bloccato al gioco è un
bug sono riusciti a trovare un bug in
mezzo ad erchie la gamma solo io li
trovo ibarbo ultimamente mi sto trovando
tutti io c'è dio mio come faccio alpi
raga che cazzo devo fare qui si è pagato
il gioco deve uscire se non posso
neanche uscirne volevo spegne a perfetto
la gara allora taglio ci vediamo dopo
allora abbiamo capito che dobbiamo
dobbiamo spostare il vaso in avanti e
possibilmente non dobbiamo ri spostarlo
perché se non si paga il gioco va bene
non lo faccio avevo trovato la soluzione
e sono riuscito a trovare un bug che è
impossibile ma i giudizi ce l'ho fatta
perfetto adesso me ne vado me ne vado
perché sei bloccato qui cosa che viene
fatto perfetto by così e salviamo quel
deficiente oh cazzo se chiuso di nuovo
al letto allora adesso risolviamo
risolviamo qui adesso devo correre
bastardo non ce la fai
non si può fare raga impossibile cazzo è
impossibile non posso andare madonna mia
santissima
dai che ce la fai fuori brutta storia
dai dai dai dai cazzo dai cazzo cazzo ma
porca [ __ ] non si può ma si può mai
perdere così ma m un [ __ ] m
ma cazzo ecco i fatti quanto sono
stupida
ora che non lo so cosa devo chiudere
mica la porta tipo così chiude vi starà
odiando questo qui sono sicuro perfetta
andiamo avanti e ne uniqua e c'è una
bambola perfetto dalla buongiorno cos'è
madonna che bambola fantastica
devo sì sei bellissimo stato farlo
guardarti è questo questa l'enigma non
devo andare avanti e mi dico a
perpetrare cazzo ho preso una
sportellata in faccia perché non posso
passare attraverso quella porta non so
tu non puoi passare
ok è questo è quello che ha detto la
bambola in inglese perfetto all'infante
cosa devo fare allora a parte limitare
gandalf cosa dovrei fare qui non posso
passarlo adesso ci parliamo in e la
bambola e chiariamo non ho comprato il
biglietto cos'è una disco devi farmi
passare attraverso quella porta
tu non puoi passare non possa leggerlo
normale devo leggerlo così per forza
perché non mi vuoi lasciare proseguire
per la mia strada
tu non puoi passare tuono poi non basta
non leggo più così perché sennò andiamo
avanti tutto giorno e buongiorno e
l'altro dei profumi po più giorno
senti sei mica come mai la bambola di
venerdì distruggere quella bambola se
vuoi con se vuoi proseguire farla
bruciare lo spirito suo interno brucerà
anch'esso ok perfetto e dopo di questo
l'invisibile barriera che
è posto sulla porta scomparirà perfetto
fermati
cos'è successo alla bambola parla non sa
dire solo quello
pensavo fosse un nastro registrato tipo
quelle dove si ricordino e sanno dire
soltanto una cosa va bene tu credi a
quello stolto sì ci credo brutta stanza
io ti brucia come fa oggi ha ripreso
bambola spaventosa perfetto devo
bruciarla endo cazzola brucia raga ho
preso una bambola spaventosa
torniamo indietro senti zio di poi
bruciare la bambola qui perché devo
bruciarlo allarme che la brucio nella
lanterna tipo allora dobbiamo trovare
del fuoco dove l'ho lasciato le foto
alla l'accendino lo ha usato per che
cazzo ci sono dei passivi per che cazzo
ci sono dei passi prima non c'erano
e adesso te adesso la porta è aperta non
ci voglio entrare
ma cosa faccio centro perché sono
stupido e ci entro lo stesso
andiamo avanti oddio c'è il canto morto
il gatto è morto si lo vedo che è morto
non c'ha le budella che cosa dove cos'è
sta roba dell'acqua dove dove cazzo sia
raga questo e pokémon siamo arrivati
alla cedu bat
siamo arrivati in una che questa è la
rabbia e via vittoria troppo arriva la
lega pokémon sappiamo in un altro slota
andiamo avanti raga non so dove
oddio cos'è c'è qualcuno qui sì lo vedo
che c'è qualcosa qualcuno con un
coltello cazzo a cosa sta facendo cose
fa avanti indietro cosa cosa devo fare
qui ragazze è assurdo c'è uno scheletro
devo e tipo a e tv gli allenatori di
pokémon la guerra che è questa parte
uguale a poche ma prima tu non devi non
devi farti ho trovato un osso posso cane
devo tornare dal cane da lì l'osso
magari mi dava accendino raga questo
esattamente uguale a pokémon non devi
farti beccare perché sennò ti sfidano
gli appare punto esclamativo in testa o
quella pokémon devo andare avanti
ok perfetto allora ce la posso fare
cos'è questo lo sposto aia usa forza ok
non funzionava andiamo avanti qua c'è
una pietra di mezzo
devo tipo ok perfetto di qua non guarda
ora devo andare di qua ma io posso no
kat
ma questi vedono anche in diagonale
oddio in poche ma non funzionava così
malizia ma no a mio zio mi ascolta
ma no dai che cazzo è una bambina non
potete fare ste cose nei video ma da
aica ma sto gioco e violento sarà anche
fatto a pixel mai violento maledizione è
non volevo scusami aia perdonami per la
pugnalata sì non devo guardarlo capito
volevo dire non posso passarci vicino
devo passarci quando non mi guarda
allora io tornerei indietro facciamo
stacco cazzo oddio sto cadendo male
dizionari non è da z mai perché basta
remix l'aveva mai così vai così male
cristiana ce l'ho fatta maledizione
manco ezio si fa a rampl i care così
bajaj a mamma mia
ezio connor e altair ti fanno una gran
pippa
vabbè allora andiamo avanti salviamo
prima che casco di nuovo devo dare
l'osso al cane in modo che mi dia
qualcosa in cambio che spero che sia un
accendino per bruciare la
cioè la bambola ragazzi c'è un tizio di
là che probabilmente ha dei problemi di
torcicollo e se non mi sbaglio non hai
il prezzo di sotto ciao fosse corretta
può sentire o un osso qui ti serve
perché dopo dovevo dartelo mi hanno
detto perfetto sai qualcosa per me è una
gemma una jet set io ho fatto sto casino
per una [ __ ] gemma va bene che mi
serva a sbloccare i finali ma a me
serviva un accendino
non è che me lo deve dare il tizio lì no
perché lì non ci vado io lì non ci vado
ma letizia allora sentite ragazze dove
entrai qui dentro bouryka [ __ ] che io
già ve ne pento
vabbè entriamo che cazzo senti zio paga
è andato a comprare qualcosa per il
torcicollo non c'è più
ho trovato si è una grande pozza di
sangue la vedo
sarà mica andato qui dietro no perché io
sono un deficiente lo vado anche a
cercare e non c'è non c'è non c'è non
c'è più va bene allora andiamo via non
ci tengo non ci tengo a incontrarlo non
ci tengo allora raga devo passare di qua
di sicuro il problema è che non so come
passare perché c'è stati pa qui si fa da
un corridoio all'altro adesso vai o
cazzo c'è un basta vai dentro mai detto
mamma mia che estelle personali slay che
ti fa anche solid snake ti fa una bocca
sei fantastica aia mamma mia che stealth
manco splinter cell
devo cazzo che stava arriva però torna
indietro non mi ha visto perfetto della
devo c'è un'altra lieta allo ragazzi c'è
qualcuno li non so se mi sfida spero di
no spero vivamente di no se non mi butto
dentro piuttosto allora fa che non i
fidi vai così
ok siamo passati era una statua e allora
presumo che si possa parlare sembra è
difficile da vedere ma sembra una
bambola è ok allora non mi interessa
sincero devo mica dargli l'altra bambola
non penso anche perché qui perché è
diventato tutto grigio raga non ho
capito
oddio che è successo è e tipo
allora ragazzi
cazzo sta girando sta facendo ragazze è
caduta la testa alla bambola e allo
stesso convento è uscita una tipa dal
buco del muro perfetto non è normale sta
cosa ma io entro nel boca non c entro il
buco ci ha ripensato subito vai così la
mamma mia una gemma una gemma ce l'ho
fatta allora dobbiamo rimanere qui
speriamo che non arrivi superiori no ok
ok piano calmissimi calmi bye bye la
madonna ci facciamo vai così vai così
sam fisher non è nessuno i confrontate
vai così vai vai vai o mio dio
mission impossible benissimo ci siamo
ragazzi la possiamo andare avanti si
spera queste questo è un classico dei po
questa gira devo stare attento a non
farmi vedere allora vai così vai così ma
mai così una donna ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok no merda tempismo 0 proprio vai così
vai così vai così se ce l'abbiamo fatta
fatemi salva questo può essere un
problema
questo può essere un [ __ ] problema è
se quella fare mi vede son cazzi come fa
allora vi faccio così vai torna indietro
torna in torno torno in jazz no è
scappato non mi ha visto magari suoi
occhi vedono male andiamo avanti c'è
allora qua paranormal pattumiera
ci siamo se il paranormal in pattumiere
che qualcuno sta gridando cosa stai
facendo cosa che sta succedendo sta
gridando qualcuno all'interno di quella
cella perché ho aiutarla così tanto
salvare non riusciremo mai a tornare
normali perché non portiamo tutti quanti
qui sarà divertente
ok con chi stanno parlando ok fermate
stuprando qualcuno o cazzo sei sentito
un rumore che non mi è piaciuto per
niente però va bene chi porta e spero
che non sia il tipo con senza l'occhio
che mi voleva aiutare no con le morto
perché l'ha uccisa maria maledetta
stronza quella che uccide la gente così
quel che gli dà il diritto di uccidere
la gente maledizione
e vabbè andiamo avanti qualcuno non
voglio entrare
sono curiosa a proposito di quella porta
bene io no andiamo avanti no devi essere
stronza perché c'è qualcuno li che
uccide e tu devi entrare sì
speriamo cazzo raga
c'è un morto maledizione c'è un coltello
nel suo petto
prendi il coltello sì prendiamo il
coltello tanto a sto punto non mi
stupisco più di ferro perché c'è un
coltello o mio dio
ahi ahi ottenuto coltello perfetto ci
siamo volevo soltanto far parte della
tua famiglia perché no a voler in a ma
per che cosa è successo
sembra che contenga sostanze misteriose
e paranormal patto non la voglio aprire
sinceramente vabbè a sto punto direi di
andare avanti perché dico non posso
passare la porta è chiusa perfetto
allora me lo posso passare neanche raga
raga paranormal pattumiera stavolta
davvero era dai cazzo eravate graggio
che lo vedeva un sacchetto
dell'immondizia che si muoveva questo è
un evento
ok è bene c'è qualcuno lì dentro
paranormal paranormal sto cazzo contiene
non mi interessa cosa contiene aprite si
muove qualcuno di dentro andiamo via
perfetto nomi anche qui c'è mica
qualcuno che qui dentro no perfetto
andiamo avanti e non mi piace il suo
posto non è normale sta cosa perché si
muove la pattumiera perché non è normale
vabbè andiamo o trovato un link o cos'è
sta roba è un lingotto è una chiave ma
se più grande della tua testa come fa
essere una chiave cosa cosa che qualcuno
o no cazzo no no la chiara nola prendere
sbattitene la chiave via via è il caos
mio cane di penombra quel che ci fa qui
raga sono tutti no mi sta fondendo la
chiave maledetto stronzo sapevo che ci
saremmo rivisti un giorno il cane sta
potendola chiara ragazzi va beh la
chiave è andata la [ __ ] perfetto
siamo nella merda ha [ __ ] la chiave
fantastico per penombra state tranquilli
che l'episodio da un'ora insieme a
quello di scribblenauts lo farò appena
iniziano le vacanze state tranquilli
no perché se non lo chiedete in 50 mila
anche se l'ho detto già un miliardo di
volte vabbè andiamo avanti o cazzo mi va
bene così mi è servito a salvare
ragaglia dire che questo episodio lo
concludo qui
perché non è normale e guardate dove
cazzo sono arrivato
ok raga io sto gioco ogni [ __ ]
episodio lo amo sempre di più è
fantastico che ho comunque questo
episodio lo concludo qui prossimo se
riesco lo faccio anche in breve perché
dall ultimo questo è passata un'eternità
scusatemi veramente come al solito
ragazze video è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione dei nostri iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi